hey guys my name is Jessa McDonald today
is the 7th of April and you're watching
games by noon the witches re may already
be delivering you over 200 hours of
playtime but now developers that app
react red has confirmed its two major
expansion packs are also on the horizon
in addition to the 16 free DLC content
packs they've already announced these
new expansion packs will cost you some
dollars and promised to offer up 30
extra hours of gameplay the first pack
is called hearts of stone where you'll
head to a place called no man's land
with a meaty quest to dig into the
second expansion called blood and wine
will be set in a new region called to
song where girls will unravel a quilt
bloody secret both packs will come with
new gear enemies and returning
characters as well as new ones hearts of
stone will be out in October while blood
and wine is expected sometime early next
year pricing for the expansion pass is
yet to be announced a new day sex game
is in the works it's called mankind
divided and here's everything you need
to know about it the game is set in 2029
two years after the events of deus ex
human revolution and will again feature
protagonist Adam Jensen near gas
uncovered a set of images and details
from Deus Ex mankind divided on a
Russian website and it was later
confirmed by game informer where they
revealed that the game will be their
cover feature from May the game doesn't
have any sort of release date as yet but
it will be coming to xbox one ps4 and PC
the information we have so far suggests
that mankind divided will feature a
similar style of play to its predecessor
although this time around you'll need to
take on smarter enemies who work in
groups as opposed to individuals that
can be picked off in a fairly cool
series of events one clever gamer has
uncovered what appears to be a teaser
video for black ops 3 and update to the
console editions of black ops 2 deployed
a number of ghost image
is that are actually snapchat friend
request codes into some of the game's
multiplayer maps once activated the
codes take you to a video on call of
duty snapchat the video only runs for 10
seconds and features a blinking I a man
saying listen only to the sound of my
voice and what appears to be a whole
bunch of trees followed by a tree all on
its own some people have suspected that
the roman numeral 3 is hidden in the
shadows of the forest image and it's
suspected that the video is somehow
related to call of duty black ops 3 let
me know down in the comments if you're
more excited for black ops 3 or j sex
mankind divided and why you can edge
against what we've got stories on a new
blood-borne exploit and NBA 2k14 why can
say that is all the good stuff that i
have for you today as always let me know
what you cared about and i'll catch you
same time tomorrow